when you're given a script do you read
the entire screenplay or only the parts
that you're playing
um interesting question
depends on the time
I mean if you have a very rapid
turnaround for the audition that you you
may not be able to read the whole
screenplay
um you
uh uh there's a there's a an old actor
expression where they go I won't say the
swear word because bsbs BS my line BS
bsbs my line
um De Niro I don't know okay I don't
know I said that but uh
I like to read the script if I have time
sometimes they don't send you the script
by the way
sometimes the script's embargoed you
don't have a chance to read it if it's a
show that's on the air you can watch an
episode or two and get a feel for it for
the world and the tone and the genre of
the show but ideally if you could read
the script yeah I coached somebody
yesterday who
it's the most weird audition we
she comes to me to help explain this
stuff and I said I'm I'm I'm lost with
you
and they didn't send her the script I
said so we just have to do a little
educated guessing because I don't really
know what this scene here means exactly
in the larger tapestry of the story
so but yeah in an Ideal World if you
have the time and they give you the
script if it's a movie they usually give
you the script if it's an episodic
television show
you generally get just your sides your
scenes and you get uh you have the
opportunity to
watch an episode or two if you have time
to do that that helps a lot that that
definitely helps a lot because then you
kind of know what is what the world is
that you're entering I did a thing oh my
this is such an embarrassing story but
I'll tell it because I didn't I was a
snob at one point
um and um I booked a guest star on
Melrose Place the original Melrose Place
I'd never watched the show
I shot the show I never watched my
episode because I just it's I thought oh
I'm above Melrose Place I'm not that you
know stupid of me anyway
did you ever watch that show I was an
extra on it okay so you remember the set
with the pool and all that stuff so I
show up the first day of work
uh second ID is taking me to wherever
the dressing room or wardrobe areas and
I see this set and I go wow
that's amazing what is this
and she said to me this is not Rose
Place
aha
I'm an idiot I mean it was so
embarrassing because I didn't know the
show I booked it and I shot it
but that was a really stupid move
on my part I mean it was arrogant it was
it was it was a bad it was a bad moment
but you have to understand you know so
let's get back to your original question
do you read the script
you have however whether it's the script
or watching something online now which
when Melrose Place was on we didn't have
that I don't think it was on but you
your job is to figure out what world
you're entering
so if you can read the script fantastic
if you don't get it you've got to figure
it out other ways and that's
it comes down to that it comes down to
to the world that you're entering more
and more now shows our
um a particular world
Yellowstone is a world I mean it's an
incredible world and all these shows and
so you really do have to understand
uh what the transaction is what what
your part in that transaction is but
yeah if you can read the script great
but you know reading reading a full
script for a movie that takes an hour
hour and a half sometimes you don't have
that time you skim it or you get you
know you'll get when the audition comes
in you'll get a storyline generally
speaking you've got a storyline of what
this is about you'll get a character
description sometimes they're useful
sometimes they're not because sometimes
the person who writes them is is the
third assistant who may or may not know
really in a granular way what they're
what they're describing so and sometimes
it's just educated guessing
and it's easier in a way than it used to
be because you can look at things and
say oh or you can research that director
or that writer
you get an idea of of what it is you're
entering into
did you go back and watch that episode
of Melrose yeah it should be somewhere
online I'm sure it is I've never watched
no you haven't okay no it's all right
I'm I'm good okay I'm good I don't need
to see it okay I'm sure it's fine what
is your process for breaking down a
screenplay
um well if I have the time I obviously
will read the whole screenplay
and I want to know
I want to know what
the larger Arc of the story is first of
all I just want to know what this is
what is this story we're all telling
breaking it down
um
for an actor is very different than
breaking it down for like a director or
a DP or somebody like that
um I think that
my process
is pretty
external in a way I will sort of
I had a Epiphany when I was in college
because they were teaching
kind of method-based acting and I I just
didn't get it I went oh I don't get this
this doesn't work for me
and I went into I was doing some play
and I went into the costume shop and I
was looking for a jacket or a coat and I
found this coat and I put it on I went
and I watched myself in the mirror went
oh
oh that's the guy
so I found out that I work externally
and once the externals are in place
I can fill it in emotionally but I need
to know
kind of the north south east and west of
the scene like okay there's the window
there's the door
I I need to know physically and whether
it's evident in the script or whether
it's just
my imagination
uh I kind of need to know that
that's me that isn't necessarily the way
to do it that's the way I do it I think
everybody has a different technique I
think all roads lead to Rome you just
got to get to Rome and everybody's
different and some people are very
internal and very emotionally I'm not I
I fill that out later once I get the
structure of it and that's kind of the
similar way that I worked when I worked
in the theater in a way as well I gotta
I have to find the structure of it
once I feel confident that once I know
the words I have to know the words
can't be thinking about the words
uh then I feel I can fill it in I can
fill it in but you know a lot of roles
that one does aren't even emotionally
that
you know they're functionary you're a
lawyer and you're and you're doing a
courtroom scene and there isn't a
tremendous amount of emotional stuff
there it's all functionary stuff to
drive the plot forward and you also have
to understand that
like
like a co-star role is generally that
it's somebody who they interview for one
scene who tells you something about the
murder suspect and then you never see
them again right so you have to
understand the function of the role
those smaller roles are frankly harder
because you have very few opportunities
to really make
Impressions wrong word but to sort of
establish who your character is
and it's usually just you know if it's
it's all about casting if I'm well cast
it makes perfect sense and it's real
easy for me to break it down and figure
out where I have to be I did a movie in
2021
the audition was entirely improved they
said these are the characters you're
dealing with this is your wife this is
your nephew and it was a kind of a
really good really good film it came
came out just great just won a big award
up at cinequest
but there was very little on the page
very little on the page it was like uh
uh it was like it's about a family it's
about a death in the family it's about
um
problems relating to money and finances
and all that stuff and there's it's a
Jewish Family and there's like aunts and
uncles and they're like the Jewish Greek
chorus so they're kind of everywhere
they're in every scene but there wasn't
really a lot on the page so how do you
break that down
you kind of don't break that down you're
cast to be like oh he or she is the
right person for that oh you're playing
my wife perfect that looks great if you
know it makes sense uh chemistry wise
but I couldn't there's no way I could
break that down because
you know there were two or three scenes
but we were in many many more scenes
than that and we uh
add a dialogue that wasn't there as well
so uh that's a whole different thing I
mean the Improv thing I'm not trained in
improv but I like doing it as an
exercise it's fun and it's freeing and
it was fun to do an audition that way
because I didn't have to memorize it but
how could I break down that script I
really couldn't
I just had to show up as that guy you
know and TR and also trust that trust is
the name of the movie by the way and
trust that
um
what you have is right and what and what
you'll and you will you feed off of the
other people in a bit in that case in
particular because it really was this
this
six-person Ensemble of relatives who
were in every scene and making
everybody's life a little crazy so
um the only danger with that is like uh
uh padding it too much trying to make
more of it than it is
you got to be careful about that we we
had uh
one actor who may name us who
is problematic that way but it's
understanding the world it's
understanding and how you break it down
is it's different for every project I
guess is the way I would I would
understand that if it's two or three
strong scenes where you have a definite
thing to do your your prosecuting
attorney you're the social worker you're
the doctor
those are kind of functionary scenes
that do carry an emotional uh weight if
it's a good script
so I'm very word oriented I mean that's
the other thing I'm extremely word
oriented I believe in literally being
forensic with the words like oh and I
will use this as a teaching technique
what's the most important word in that
sentence and why
and there's usually a reason and and
it's like figuring out
where where that where that lives I mean
it's really important to be I mean that
that was something that was really
um imbued in me from working in the
theater for many many years is the text
is everything and so and in the theater
you can't change a thing you cannot
change a word
so you have to work with what you have
if the text
isn't great you find a way to make it
great that's your job is to make it
better than it is
that's the actor's job is to make bad
writing be better than it appears to be
I mean sometimes I I coached an audition
the other day and
when we were done with this young woman
did a great job I said it's better than
they deserve he did a great job because
sometimes that's what it is
so if we were to take the line I need to
talk to you Michael
and you did that very well oh thank you
let's say I'm your boss yes and I've
discovered that you're playing online
poker we've had the I.T company this is
a great scene and so it's a sensitive
issue and we don't want the other
co-workers to know about it but we want
to keep you because we like you but we
think maybe he has a gambling problem so
I um
what what would be the forensics of that
sentence it's a very simple sentence of
I need to talk to you if I'm playing
that part either either
yeah right so right so um
it's what I call a change moment that's
a change moment in a scene
blah blah blah blah blah oh by the way I
need to talk to you okay okay can we
have sure so it's
it's identifying change moments
every time there's a change
and there are even bad writing has
changed moments in it okay so like if
you're watching television if you've got
television on in the background and it's
some local news broadcast and some
person had something horrible happen to
one of their children or you're hearing
the the newscaster he's got the
microphone and he's interviewing
somebody and there's been something
terrible happened then all of a sudden
it goes quiet
and you go
and that person's crying let's say or
whatever that silence this is the one
thing particularly theater actors have
of almost have an issue with I can't
generalize but we feel like we have to
get to the next thing we have to get to
the next thing and I'll just say find a
place in there to just be quiet
so that you let us in as soon as you're
quiet and it has to be earned
has to be earned in the scene but if you
like if you said to me
uh what is the line I uh we have to talk
what is the line you just gave me I need
to talk to you Michael
okay
uh
what is that about
do you want to come in my office
uh yeah
yeah I'll be right back so you fill it
with pauses
you fill it with thinking
I used to do an exercise called thinking
on film where basically I would say
30 seconds
I don't want you to say one word I want
you to have an idea I want you to have
something that just happened to you
it's either good or it's bad you got a
phone call that somebody just broke up
with you whatever it is I don't need to
know what it is you have a narrative in
your head you are allowed one physical
gesture and no words for 30 seconds go
and it's fascinating because people go
people know they may not know exactly
what's happening but they kind of know
and I said don't overdo it don't pretend
to be sad just it's just here it's just
in your face and in your eyes and in
your thinking so I call it thinking on
film and you can think on film and
that's the beauty you can once you get
to that point as a
practitioner film and TV acting where
you could just think something and it
it's there
that's magic I mean because we always
we're very I I'm word oriented because
that's how I was trained but sometimes
you have to leave that behind and just
be
moment oriented be quiet for a second
and let people in
so when you said about these functional
roles that you're not playing
necessarily Pacino in a courtroom scene
you might just be a corporate attorney
who's confirming dates or something and
it's not where you're going to be over
the top stealing the show right
and so people think maybe that that's
what their function is or well you have
the row has a function within the pardon
me within the story
and that's generally on a row like that
pardon me it's it's generally pretty
clear what it is
generally not a lot of subtext
unless uh there's something else going
on but if it's just a functionary thing
like legal stuff I've done a lot of
legal stuff
and yes I'm not a lawyer but I play one
on TV
um
it's kind of easy because
it's procedural and the the magic of it
is that you let your you just do it as
you you just do it so whatever your
neutral is not neutral my neutral is not
neutral no one's neutral is neutral you
come in with some core thing about who
you are that kind of plays through
everything so even if you're doing a
functionary role a role that's just
talking about uh you know some legal
thing
whatever whoever it is you are
and again as I said before this gets
more complex and more interesting as you
get older and you kind of are more at
home with who you are
uh that just is there and so that's kind
of what you were hired for in a way is
to be as I said earlier a dynamic
truthful version of who you already are
so the lines are just look the uh that
stuff it's like um
it's like a baked potato you can put
anything on a baked potato you can put
salsa you can put cream uh cream cheese
you can put sour cream you can put
chives but it's still a baked potato the
baked potato needs flavor added to it
that's kind of what we bring in a
functionary roll we add flavor to the
baked potato
I can't believe I just said that